here we go against mr. walling us so we
get this Catalan stuff right and yeah I
wanted to refresh this actually for the
games against him he plays a line that
is some if black desert black plays
correctly is really am very very dry but
I tend to I have forgotten most of it so
I hope that I can somehow remember
details while I'm playing this Winston 7
and c6 yeah you should see 694 I cannot
remember anything that's terrible now I
arcade the shifty 597 and rook e8 is
right Roxy to our god it's been years
almost that I've looked at this rock t5
and then Bishop f8 I'm not wrong it's
more than one one way to equalize but
yeah I should be there with 14 with four
minutes thirty or something it's not
good to have spent that time here yeah
the slide is the end of Bishop g5 and
the capsule on even though some people
still try that even though its sides of
course very boring stuff but you get
that against him anyway now it's looking
for ways to continue this I'll be taking
e 2 + b2 and we'll get some material
back here we had this and earlier games
actually ever screwed it up never
screwed up with route 28 coming here
hmm really what did I do wrong see one I
could have taken e to of course no I
couldn't hmm there to take them and or
am I just seeing ghosts Roxy for
it's unfortunately a direct mate this is
the problem hope da de threatening mate
immediately looking toward the AIDS hmm
maybe I can still take their look to a
g6 look f ed King g7 he's not really
able to protect f2 okay I really have
forgotten this whole line I actually
analyze it at 1.22 a complete complete
nothing now so look the 8g six Luke f8
king g 7c sandra graph to check check to
h6 sound f6 is a check on the six this
is completely unnecessary so let's go
there this does he have some kind of
tech to ignite f5 stuff if i get to take
f2 i have some we're drawing chances
maybe is it is actually ok even though
it was unplanned so taking their 93
Russia to check and I'm taking tons of
pawns you look c2 was probably okay
okay too am I too optimistic in thinking
that this should be okay I mean I have
three ponds h2 is hanging and there are
some ideas even to play for meat so I
hasn't he screwed this up it leads to
some degree
now I can take their 40 h 1 meter cannot
be too bad taking stuff rooty to rookie
one on the first look is 70 just about
saves it
Jim it's probably more than one thing
that's good let's do this check and no
here I don't know did I have something
better check
Scott 95
threatening a week with you one it's a
pretty annoying threat okay
so let's see maybe I kind learning over
here and keep that pawn so I can still
double why not and 5.5 pounds at the end
of you I hope $96 okay let's keep it
don't want to give you any porn he
actually is down on time now any kind of
mates coming check and 96 or something
so mate g5 check we will take it huh I
shouldn't go into 95 meet this is really
not something I want to allow playing it
badly really him giving him some kind of
ideas night f7 hmm not good check
no no checkmate ah I wanted to play g5
that is a mouse slip buddy you really
did this guy is some pact with the devil
right I just play g5g and the game is
over check unbelievable this is
unbelievable anyway I have to take it I
mean what God about what kind of game is
that ok yes so I'm really curious about
this because I'm really as i said as i
analyzed it once and I knew that this is
right so it is a draw right this is
actually ok public computer gives equal
equal everything here and here is he's
losing yeah quarter in the position was
completely winning for very long time
check even the final position as I said
and then I mouse slipped I think that
was basically okay while I did maybe
something quicker was possible to this
it is a win III everything and also that
I channeled oh it wasn't term the
clearest way possible I wanted to play
g5 here wanted to play g5 age six is the
easiest one and nothing happens so this
is really oops they're opening here yeah
he continues to play those nothing
Alliance and this is really known even
though i really had forgotten this point
that I can allow this loss of the of the
bishop I just played the moves and and I
know that they were right but I didn't
know that can this is really okay here
how does he draw actually night see one
if he plays a child I mean he didn't
play it right as i said night see one
this this is a draw check why exactly is
it a troll I mean
I mean the other question is though can
i play for win this is the question and
a tip take here and play for win 95 ok
this probably because now I have 7s I
checked on still cannot play for Winnie
as black now probably probably white
always has enough counter check here
with the rooks maybe maybe if anybody
black can try something anyway thanks
for watching